another thing Dr bright is not allowed  to do at the foundation Dr Bright's an  original idea is not always a good idea  in this age of remakes and reboots  originality can be extremely valuable  however just because an idea is original  does not mean it is good Dr bright is  correct that no one has ever tried to  test Cosmetics on scp-682 before but  that does not mean that putting lipstick  and mascara on the hard to destroy  reptile is a good plan all Foundation  Personnel are now required to attend a  seminar on the differences between an  original idea and a good idea before  being allowed to interact with Dr bright  don't let him be a bad influence on you